- Please, guys, I wanna go
have lunch at Mar-a-Lago.
(classy jazz music)
A lady cameraman.
Very strange.
What do you do
during your period?
Can you film?
Yuck.
(beeping)
I'm an excellent multitasker.
Watch this.
I think it's like that.
I used to peer in
on her all the time
when she would wear
very loose nighties.
That's how I knew my
mother was going to bed.
(beeping)
I'm doing it.
So, we cleaned up the body
and we continued
the bachelor party.
I like butt stuff.
He stepped right out
of a Bradley's catalog
and now he's the slate guy?
And I said, I'll
chop your legs off
if you ever say that again.
And she didn't believe me.
And that's why she
walks so funny.
I don't wanna touch the hair.
I'm tired, I want a hamburger.
I farted a little
bit on that one.
Everybody's out
of here, get out.